Robb Stark: The Starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years, even withstanding the
invasion of the Andals.
As the southern kingdoms fell, and the Children
were driven away, the North stood strong,
maintaining its religious customs and its
way of life.
Eventually, the reign of the Kings of Winter
came to an end with the coming of Aegon the
Conqueror.
After Aegon and his dragons destroyed the
armies of the Reach and the Rock at the Field
of Fire, King Torrhen Starkbent the knee and
swore fealty to the Targaryen dynasty in order
to spare the destruction of Winterfell and
his people.
He was forever after known as "the King Who
Knelt."
As a reward for his submission, Aegon named
TorrhenLord of Winterfell and Warden of the
North.
Sansa Stark: The North is the oldest and largest
of the Seven Kingdoms, but House Stark has
not always held it.
When Bran the Builder raised Winterfell and
founded our line, we were vassals to the Barrow
Kings, who claimed descent from the First
King and thus dominion over all the First
Men.
But after the Long Night, it was our house
who built the Wall and set the Night's Watch
to guard the realms of men whilst our king
sat in his barrow.
My ancestors eventually revolted, waging what
singers call the Thousand Years War to free
our lands.
Other families joined us, recognizing that
the North is a cold and hard land and needed
a king who served its people before himself.
Finally, the last Barrow King bent the knee,
and House Stark became the Kings of Winter.
Yet we were kings in name only.
For by then, the North had fractured into
petty kingdoms, and my ancestors would struggle
to unite it again for thousands of years.
Rodrik Stark wrestled an Ironborn lord for
Bear Island and granted it to House Mormont
when he won.
A younger son of our family, Karlon Stark,
won his own keep after he put down a rebellion
and founded House Karstark, one of the most
powerful in the North.
When the Manderlys were exiled from the Reach,
my ancestors shielded them and gave them a
home at the mouth of the White Knife in return
for holding the river against pirates and
invaders.
Now they're one of the wealthiest houses in
the North.
I'm not so naive to pretend that the entire
North welcomed Stark rule.
The last Warg King was slain at Sea Dragon
Point along with all his sons and beasts.
The last Marsh King died at the hands of King
Rickard Stark, and House Reed has held the
swamps of the Neck ever since.
Houses Greenwood, Towers, Amber, Frost.
None survive today as more than names in dusty
old books.
But my ancestors never wanted to destroy their
foes root and stem.
The Umbers of Last Hearth and the Glovers
of Deepwood Mottebent the knee and became
loyal vassals of House Stark.
The Red Kings of House Bolton wore cloaks
made from the skins of Stark princes they'd
flayed, and one of the Boltons was even known
as the Redarm because he liked to plunge an
arm into the bellies of captive Starks and
pull out their entrails with his bare hand.
The North deserved to be wiped clean of them.
Yet my ancestors spared them after their defeat
because they believed the North couldn't afford
to fight itself any longer.
Time soon proved them right.
When the Andals swept into Westeros, they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the First
Men except the North.
Each of the southern kingdoms fought the invaders
on its own, but the North fought as one.
When the Andals tried to sail on the White
Knife, the Manderlys fell on their ships.
When the Andals tried to march an army through
the Neck, the Reeds fell on their soldiers.
King Theon Stark even sailed his own army
to the Andalhomeland for vengeance and slew
hundreds of Andal warriors.
When he returned, he planted their heads on
spikes along our coasts — a warning to other
would-be conquerors.
The warning was heeded for thousands of years,
until Aegon the Conqueror.
The south had already fallen to Aegon and
his dragons.
Only the North remained.
My ancestor, King Torrhen Stark, marched the
North down to the Trident and beheld Aegon's
army, larger than Torrhen's own by half and
with three dragons circling overhead.
Many northern bannermen wanted to attack anyway,
claiming northern valor would carry the day.
Others wanted to fall back to Moat Cailin
and make a stand there.
But Torrhen had heard how the armies of the
Rock and the Reach had burned on the Field
of Fire and had seen the fires still glowing
beneath the rubble of Harrenhal.
He knelt and laid his ancient crown as Aegon's
feet and rose a king no more but Lord of Winterfell
and Warden of the North.
Some Northerners still sneer at my ancestor
as "The King Who Knelt," forgetting that because
of Torrhen, they're alive today to sneer.
Their ancestors didn't leave their burned
bones at the Trident, and their twisted swords
didn't fill Aegon'snew throne.
Roose Bolton: Brandon the Builder, founder
of House Stark, raised Winterfell with giants
over eight thousand years ago.
Or so nursemaids tell all the children of
the North.
The children nod, wide-eyed, unaware of the
lesson forced on them.
That if even giants obeyed a Stark, so too
should they.
But like every other castle, Winterfell was
built in pieces over thousands of years.
The First Men settled there because of the
hot springs that bubbled through the ground.
The water and the heat helped them survive
the Northern winters, and they built defenses
to keep it for themselves.
Nobody raised the castle all at once, probably
nobody meant to raise a castle at all.
In those days, the Starks were not the greatest
house in the North, and Winterfell was not
the greatest castle.
Barrowton was the oldest, dating to the First
King, and the Starks fought the Barrow Kings
for a thousand years.
Greywater Watch was, like the crannogmen themselves,
the strangest.
Only marriage subdued its Marsh Kings.
But the greatest rival to Winterfell was always
the Dreadfort, and my ancestors, the Red Kings
of House Bolton.
If tales can be believed, we fought from the
Long Night until the Andals came.
Because of us, Winterfell raised its first
walls, but we took and burned that castle
anyway.
Winterfell built more keeps, more walls, more
guard towers.
They expanded the granaries and larders to
survive our sieges.
They tended the godswood to win favor with
the Old Gods against us.
As the castle grew, more farmers and villagers
flocked every winter from across the North
to huddle under its walls, raising the winter
town.
In the spring these villagers would find themselves
marching in the Stark armies to fight against
us.
The greatness of Winterfell is as much our
doing as the Starks.
But in the end, neither its stone walls nor
its tall keeps and iron gates could save Winterfell.
At its height, it could have lasted a year
under heavy siege.
But a handful of ironborn seized it in the
night, while its lord, the King in the North,
was playing in the south.
My dagger ended his reign.
Jon Snow: As a boy, looking out from my father's
castle, I thought the sun could never set
on the North.
So vast did it seem.
A part of me still does.
The North is by far the largest of the Seven
Kingdoms and can fit the other six inside
it.
Not that the others care.
Cold and damp, that's how the southerners
see the North.
But without the cold, a man can't appreciate
the fire in his hearth.
Without the rain, a man can't appreciate the
roof over his head.
Let the south have its sun, flowers, and affectations,
we Northerners have home.
Mine was once Winterfell, the ancient seat
of my father's family, House Stark, who have
ruled the North since the First Men and were
once the Kings of Winter.
Growing up, Lady Catelyn made sure I knew
I wasn't a Stark, no matter how much blood
I shared with her trueborn children.
But where their name rules over the North,
mine is the North.
Snow.
Our lands stretches from the Wall down to
the Neck, a narrow land that divides it from
the rest of Westeros.
Legend has it that the Children of the Forestflooded
it in their war against the First Men.
If that's true, every Northman owes them a
debt of gratitude.
The swamps of the Neck are as good as the
Wall for keeping out unwelcome armies.
And if the swamps don't deter you, the crannogmen
should.
Small, shy people who rarely leave those swamps
and who follow House Reed, the gatekeepers
of the North, and among the most important
and loyal bannermen of House Stark.
Also a bit strange.
I heard their oath of fealty once as a child.
It's is like no other lords'.
Ancient and dark, they swear by earth and
water, by bronze and iron, and by ice and
fire.
Where House Reed holds the gate to the North,
House Manderly holds the port.
White Harbor, the closest thing to a southern
city we have governed by the closest thing
to a southern family we have.
Generations ago, the Manderlys were driven
from the Reach, but the Starks gave them their
land in return for fealty.
Now White Harbor is the richest city of the
North, and the Manderlys the richest family.
Not in gold and silver like their southern
counterparts, but in fish and grain and trade.
As for the other great Northern houses, the
Starks brought them into the fold during the
Age of Heroes.
A Stark wrestled an ironborn for Bear Island
and gave it to the Mormonts.
A Stark granted a keep and land to a younger
son, Karlon, in return for putting down a
rebellion.
His family then grew up into the Karstarks.
Starks fought the wildlings and their Kings-Beyond-the-Wall
beside the Umbers of Last Hearth, thus earning
their fealty.
Boltons.
Back then, they were the bane of the North.
A few were even rumored to wear their enemies'
flayed skins as cloaks.
But after centuries of war, they too bent
the knee.
And so House Stark became the Kings in the
North, but never forgot that they weren't
the North.
When Aegon and his dragons landed on Westeros,
the Kings of the Rock and the Reach sent all
of their men to die to defend their grounds.
Torrhen Stark knelt to spare his people the
same fate.
He placed duty above pride.